for years now i've been talking to tons
of different people every single day
some of them are very excited about
bitcoin others aren't excited at all one
of the things that i spend a lot of my
time on is trying to understand the
people who aren't excited what's keeping
them from actually going and spending
the time to learn about bitcoin or to
potentially understand why it could be
so valuable for them and their family i
saw a recent write-up in the in bitcoin
we trust newsletter by sylvan sorrell
and i thought that it was really well
done going ahead and taking a look at
the reasons why a lot of people aren't
excited about bitcoin the first point
that sylvan made was that a lot of
people think that bitcoin is only used
by criminals or by nefarious actors well
that's a pretty easy thing to get over
once you actually look at the data what
we can see is that the illicit share of
all cryptocurrency transaction volumes
has been dropping significantly over the
last few years according to the chain
analysis less than 0.2 percent of all
transactions in 2021 were due to illicit
activities there's also a report from
the former cia director where he states
that his estimation is less than 0.5 of
all transactions are actually related to
illicit activities regardless of what
the exact stat is it's very obvious that
criminals choose to use the dollar and
other fiat currencies way more than they
use bitcoin or crypto currencies that's
because they don't want to be using an
asset where there's a public ledger that
their transactions are coded into
forever and anyone in the world
including law enforcement can go back
and analyze that for years to come next
we can go ahead and take a look at
something like bitcoin's volatility
which is another reason why many people
are scared of the digital currency that
volatility in most people's minds is
talking about the relationship between
bitcoin and the us dollar exchange price
obviously one bitcoin equals one bitcoin
but if you want to actually take your
bitcoin and spend it for goods or
services or you want to exchange it for
dollars there is volatility we have this
quote right here from noelle atchison
from genesis global in which he states
bitcoin is a volatile asset and in times
of uncertainty harnessing that
volatility which is usually a feature
not a bug is difficult enough to
dissuade even the most experienced
volatility traders this is especially
acute in the current market environment
given that the uncertainty is driven
largely by the war in europe and it is
hard to predict outcomes when we do not
know if the news emerging from the
conflict zone is trustworthy and so
ultimately what we're watching is
certain people like volatility and
others don't if you have a long time
horizon the volatility ends up working
in your favor the fixed supply asset and
as demand increases the price goes up
but if you're a short-term optimized
person or a trader that volatility can
definitely go against you so
understanding who you are what your
goals are what you're optimizing for end
up being really important when you're
looking at bitcoin then if we take a
look at a third criteria as to people
wanting to evaluate bitcoin there's this
idea of lost their stolen funds and
they're worried that if they actually
hold bitcoin somebody will just take it
from them well that's not necessarily
true because there are tons of different
services and exchanges where you can
purchase and store bitcoin you can go
ahead and use those services to either
buy the bitcoin and take it off of the
exchange this idea of not your keys not
your coin you can't exactly do that at
size and scale in the legacy financial
system but you also have to have great
hygiene when it comes to security you
have to remember your seed phrase the
equivalent of a password and you also
have to make sure that you follow best
practices you don't tell people how much
bitcoin you have you don't reuse
addresses you don't use public block
explorers and the many other things that
people have identified that drastically
reduce the privacy and security of you
as a bitcoin user anyone can steal
anything from anyone on the internet
someone can steal money from you they
can steal your data and your information
and yes they could steal your bitcoin as
well but if you take the proper measures
and you actually are prepared it's very
unlikely that that's going to happen to
you or anyone else you know now despite
all of these issues remember that crypto
adoption is absolutely exploding what we
see from the world bank and crypto.com
is that total internet users in 1998 is
right about where we are in 2022 for
total crypto users and this is just
another data point that suggests
regardless of the friction regardless of
the obstacles and the challenges people
want this technology they realize that
it's valuable and they're going to get
it hey you did you like this video great
we make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time